what are black holes what do we humans
understand about black holes and what's
still
unknown einstein's theory extended by
people like roger penrose tells us that
um black holes are in a sense well the
simple things basically because uh they
are um
solutions of einstein's equations um and
the thing that was shown in the 1960s by
roger penrose in particular and by a few
other people was that um
a black hole when it forms and settles
down
is defined just by two quantities its
mass and its spin
so they're actually
based standardized objects it's amazing
those objects are standardized as that
um can be so big and can lurk in the
vessel solar system
and so
that's the situation for a really formed
black hole but the way they form
obviously is very messy and complicated
and
one of the things that i've worked on a
lot is
what the phenomena are
which are best attributed to black holes
and what may lead to them and all that
and um
can you explain to that so what what
what are the different phenomena that
lead to a black hole okay let's let's
talk about it this is okay well that's
so cool so yes okay okay
well i mean i think one thing that
only became understood really in the
1950s i suppose and beyond was
how stars evolve differently depending
on how heavy they are yeah this the sun
um burns hydrogen the helium and then
when it's run out of that it contracts
to be a white dwarf and we know how long
that will take about 10 billion years
altogether for its lifetime um but big
stars
burn up their fuel more quickly
and more interestingly because when
they've turned hydrogen to helium
they then get even hotter so they can
fuse helium into carbon and go up the
periodic table
and then they eventually explode
when they have an energy crisis and they
blow out that process material
which as a digression is crucially
important because um all the atoms
inside our bodies
were synthesized inside a star
a star that lived and died more than
five billion years ago before services
have formed and so we each have inside
us atoms made in thousands of different
stars all over the milky way and that's
an amazing idea and my predecessor fred
hoyle in 1946 was the first person to
suggest that idea and that's been borne
out that's a wonderful idea um so um
that's
how massive stars explode and they leave
behind
something which
is very exotic and of two kinds one
possibility is a neutron star and these
were first discovered in 1967
68.
these are stars a bit heavier than the
sun
which are compressed to an amazing
density so the whole mass of more than
the sun's mass is in something about 10
miles across
so um they're extraordinarily dense
they're exotic physics
um and
they they've been
they've been studied in immense detail
and they've been real laboratories
because the good thing about astronomy
apart from
exploring what's out there is to use the
fact that the cosmos has provided us
with a lab
with far more extreme conditions that we
could ever simulate and so we learn lots
of basic physics from looking at these
objects um and that's been true neutrons
but for black holes
that's even more true because the um uh
bigger stars
when they collapse they
leave something behind in the center
which is too big to be a stable by two
or four neutron star becomes a black
hole
and we know that there are lots of black
holes weighing about
10 or up to 50 times as much as the
sun which are the remnants of stars they
were detected first 50 years ago
when a black hole was orbiting around
another star
and grabbing material from the other
star which swirled into it and gave us
x-rays so the x-rays astronomers found
these um uh
objects orbiting around an ordinary star
and emitting x-ray radiation very
intensely
varying on a baseball time scale so
something very small and dense was
giving that radiation that was the first
evidence for black holes but then the
other thing that happened was realizing
that there was a
different class of monster black holes
in the center of galaxies
and
these are responsible what's called
quasars which is when uh um something in
the center of a galaxy
is grabbing some fuel and outshines all
the
100 billion stars or so in the rest of
the galaxy giant beam
that's got to be the most epic thing the
universe produces is quasars
um well it's a it's a debate about the
most epic but
quasars maybe or maybe gamma ray bursts
or something but but they're they are
remarkable and that they were a mystery
for a long time and they weren't things
i worked on in my
younger days so even though they're so
bright they're still a mystery and but
well i wouldn't say i can only see them
there's a little mystery now i think we
do understand basically what's going on
how were quasars discovered
well they were discovered when
astronomers found things that looked
like stars and that they were small
enough to be a point like and not
resolved by a telescope
but uh uh outshone an entire galaxy yeah
and uh that is suspicious yes
but uh um but then they they realized
that what they were
they were um
objects which you now know are black
holes
and they were um
black holes were capturing gas
and that gas was getting very hot but it
was producing um
far more energy than all the stars added
together and it was the energy of the uh
black hole
that was um lighting up all the gas in
the galaxy so you've got a spectrum of
it uh there so so
this was something which was realized
from the 1970s onwards um and uh as you
say the other thing we've learned is
that they often do produce these jets
squirting out
um which could be detected in uh in all
wave bands so um there's now a standard
picture yeah black hole generating jets
of light yeah the center of most
galaxies yes that's right do we know
do you have a sense if every galaxy has
one of these big
big boys big black holes most galaxies
have big black holes they vary in size
the one in our galactic center do we
know much about ours
we we do yes we um we know um
it weighs about as much as 4 million
suns
uh which is less than some is there
several billions in other galaxies um
and but we know this um the one narcotic
center isn't
very bright or conspicuous and that's
because not much is falling into it at
the moment if if a black hole is
isolated then of course it doesn't
radiate it only
all that radiates is gas
swirling into it
which is very hot or has magnetic fields
that's only radiating the thing it's
murdering or consuming right or however
you put it yeah that's right and so so
um it's thought that our galaxy may have
been bright bright at some time in the
past but now uh
and that's when the black hole formed or
grew
but but now it's uh not um capturing
very much gas and so it's it's rather
it's one of the faints and uh very
detected indirectly and by fairly weak
radio emission and uh and so i think the
answer to your question is that um
we suspect that most galaxies have a
black hole in them
so that means at some stage in their
lives
or maybe one or more stages they went
through a phase of being like a quasar
where that black hole um captured gas
and became very very bright
but for the rest of their lives the
black holes are fairly questioned
because there's not much gas
falling into them
and so this universe of ours is
sprinkled a bunch of galaxies and giant
black holes it was
like
very large number of stars
uh orbiting these black holes and then
planets orbiting
likely it seems like
planets orbiting almost every one of
those stars
and just this beautiful universe of ours
well what happens when galaxies collide
when these two big black holes
collide is that
is it
well um what would happen is that uh
well and i should say that um this is
going to happen near us one day but not
for four billion years because the
andromeda galaxy which is the biggest
galaxy
near to us which is about
nearly three million light years away
which is a big disc galaxy with the
black holes hub rather like our milky
way and um that's uh um in falling
towards us because they're both in a
common gravitational potential well and
um uh that will collide with our galaxy
in about four billion years but it'll be
it'd be
maybe it'd be less a collision and more
of a dance because it'll be like a
swirling situation
but eventually there'll be to be a
merger they'll go through each other and
then merge in fact uh um the nice movies
to be made of this you know computer
simulations yes and it'll go through um
and um
and then um
there's a black hole in the sense of
andromeda and our galaxy and the galax
the black holes will uh
settle towards the center yes
then they will orbit around each other
very fast and then they will eventually
merge
and that'll produce a big burst of
gravitational waves
um very big burst that an alien
civilization with a lego-like detector
would be able to detect yes well in fact
we will but we can detect these with
them
they're lower frequencies than the uh
ways that to be detected by ligo so
there's a
space interferometer which can detect
these they're about it's about one cycle
per hour rather than about a hundred
cycles per second yes the ones that
detect it um but
that that will happen but um uh thinking
back to what will happen in four billion
years to uh any of our descendants
they'll be okay because the um
the the two disc galaxies will merge
it'll end up as a sort of amorphous
elliptical galaxy but um the stars won't
be much closer together they are now
it'll it'll still be just twice as many
stars in the structure almost as big and
so um uh the chance of another star
colliding with our sun would still be
very small and yeah because there's
actually a lot of space between indeed
stars and planets yes the chance of a
star getting close enough to affect our
solar system's orbit is small and it
won't change that very much so
we could be reassured a heck of a starry
sky though
what would that look well it won't make
much difference even that actually it'll
just be um
wouldn't that look kind of beautiful
when you're swirling or is it oh because
it's scrolling so slowly yeah
but they're far away so we just retwise
as many stars in the sky yeah and but
the pattern changes
yeah the pattern will change a bit and
uh there won't be the milky way because
the milky way
across the sky is because we are looking
in the disk of our galaxy and uh you
lose that and because the um the disc
will be so disrupted and uh it'll be
also the spherical distribution and of
course many characters are like that um
and that's probably because they have
been through mergers of this kind
you